devant 18e jour de trop pour une petite
compilation de jeux gratuits c'est parti
[Musique]
oui maintenant ce rituel were un jeu
dans lequel va devoir faire des tâches
quotidiennes
c'est parti je crois que c'est
chronométrés ces sages top-10 alarme
s'est fait à les suivants open your eyes
jour pas trouvé mieux comme ça le matin
mais c'est une technique par elle aussi
retire tes poils de nez mais mes super
dangereux de faire ça ça fait hyper mal
il faut vraiment pas vers ça mais du
café ouais ouais ouais ok way attrape le
bus mais la plus totale mec
ok tant est qu'elle vend le bus va cette
vie tu vas là au quatrième étage ouais
ok ouais ouais attraper le mouton
vaseuses et normal tous les jours on
attend des [ __ ] de moutons prépare
qu'est ce qu'il fait il prépare un
rituel démoniaque la [ __ ] c'est fini
on a les simulateurs on a foiré les
rituels ok on est au top et c'est que
cette fois la démo va arriver un
cinquième siècle mais arrêtez [ __ ]
retire tes vêtements à temps mais on
commence avec le démoniaque et ont fini
par enlever nos vêtements qu'est ce que
c'est que ce bordel
ok il avait emménagé au dubitatif on
leur père il faut que je lave hockey
rebelles alarme way a donc ça c'est la
journée du mec quoi voilà super on a
réussi donc
scor 4405 4402 [ __ ] je me dis qu'est
super merci d'avoir joué bas c'était le
jeu le plus rapide du monde pour
finalement faire ce que je fais déjà
tous les jours
[Musique]
on al'intention reach blablo et c'est un
jeu excellent parce qu'on va encore fait
un truc qui nous arrive tous les jours
marché avec son téléphone et de voir
esquiver des gens je sais pas au hockey
au loin derrière plan les trucs arrivée
d'accord donc du coup je dois je vous
supplie quelqu'un et comment je fais
pour baisser le téléphone faut que je
like faut que je réponde bla bla bla ou
qui est un des opus j'ai trop d'humains
dans la rue régulièrement je prends des
poteaux comme ça voilà ça va forcément
moyen de 2 le à ok c'est comme ça
d'accord et du coup on va se faire des
amis like et tous leurs trucs sans se
prendre deux mamies regarder la lune
frustré voilà on va pas se prendre le
chien qui pisse
[ __ ] mais jusqu'où la douala le poteau
fait la ola screamer oh la vache ma
petite copine est trop charmante et oued
souf
oh le poteau mais là je me le suis pris
deux côtés de la route devrait pas me
tuer ramène en regard des jeux puisque
rôle est beaucoup plus vite [ __ ] je
suis débile des cheveux scrollé hyper
vite tu es en plus des gens ils disent
des trucs nul on s'en fou tellement et
un éclair à qui met une photo d'elle
avec des grosses bouche atteint dooya
des bouches d'égout verte avec une dame
et n'importe quoi rtas je m'en bats les
attend oui autant giratoire gones même
sur les chances d'éviter a pas autant de
gens à la sortie d'une maison de
retraite à celle fille devant le colisée
je m'emballe est à croquer comme quoi
quand j'ai tourné dans un trou mon mec
est mort la semaine dernière dans un
accident au et moi je like comme un bon
gros fdp s'il ya bien un statut appliqué
sur facebook c'est ça mon iphone est
mort dans un violent crash when the
lights est super mon petit ami est mort
il ya quinze minutes parce qu'il avait
bataillé depuis trois jours ça peut nous
arriver à tous donc j'aime bien la la la
la la la la la c'est ça hein le chien
d'un watt en équipe et on va traverser
la grand mère c'était fantastique
le paradis du chien elle ne retire plus
téléphone on esquive parce qu'on a du
talent mais qui sait que savait kg
permet d'esquiver je veux mourir le
poteau le bon bah est la grand-mère
mascia nous avons un message nous allons
devoir se lever la face à la mafia
car actions du monde attend ça commence
brodeur damon hill à rivedoux mais il
n'y a pas un mec qui cache derrière
chaque arbre sipan ma vous m'aurez pas
señorita s'il y avait matière à tout
moment qu'est ce que tu vas me faire à
temps avec ce bol j'ai eu du team du
monde de vieilles montagnes avec est
juste un paquet de soins et des arbres
mais une musique hors du commun utiliser
prochainement temps sur revenante avec
dicaprio rossignol et à aller on s'amuse
on n'échappe à la mafia c'est super
génial
alors là ils méritent un test sur plein
de sites regardez cette belle armée ses
textures cybèle attire tous deux subi le
14 juillet et c'est le décès ouah mais
zynga mde sur 10 km et vous qu'avez-vous
est décédé à mons
[Musique]
l'asptt mulhouse avaient été kidnappés
par un groupe d'adorateurs de salade de
pommes de terre et vous êtes maintenant
forcés d'en manger trouver un moyen de
vous débarrasser de votre salade quand
ils ne regardent pas on en est là mais
qui fait des jeux comme ça le peuple
veut savoir la france veut savoir s'il
vous plaît vous avez été assommés et
kidnappé par groupes ils vous ont
enchaîné à une chaise et maintenant ils
vous force à à manger du poison des
salades et pommes de terre avec du
poison ils veulent aussi se tuer mais
ils attendront que tu meures aux
premiers mondiaux ils sont à ok des fois
ils sont attirés d'accord ok qu'est ce
que je peux faire je le mets où le chien
le chien attention pour la chaussette en
première et que je la combine avec ça
non c'est sûr y'a un truc à faire mais
que ce soit possible je veux apprendre
ça le chien le chien le chien ne viendra
pas il a l'air distrait
maintenant j'ai tellement dans le cube à
l'atome est que tu veux pas prendre ça
mais je peux rien contre abusé ouest va
toucher avec le poteau et bat toi tu es
mort mais non
à rien je sens je sors tom cruise en
veille ce corps non c'est un peu de tout
sur la télé pour les distraire faire
tomber cette [ __ ] de cannes on la
chaussette rendre la can a confectionné
une canne à chaussettes rapprocher
l'arbre à l'aide de la can à chaussettes
[ __ ] c'est long pour allumer la télé
pour les distraire à faire tomber lors
sont du coup logiquement le chien voilà
il est réveillé il est venu à nos pieds
ok on a envie d'un peu dans la plante et
on doit le rester ce [ __ ] de chiens
c'est bon y'a plus rien c'est fini votre
plan a l'air d'avoir marché ouais mais
ils ne sont pas si stupide ils vous ont
pris une fois donc pourquoi ils te
croirais en on voit les gens c'est la
fin de cette vidéo sur ces petits jeux
gratuit n'hésitez pas été chargé ce
boulet ils sont dans la description et a
aimé la vidéo ça vous a plu futur cool
de jouer à plusieurs petits jeux comme
ça qu au départ un seul mec ou deux qui
se font plaisir c'est leur passe temps
et ce fut un honneur d'être kidnappé par
des mangeurs de salade de pommes de
terre
voilà c'est une conclusion de merde pour
une vidéo à la sortie de cette vidéo
merci d'avoir gardé john numbi
[Musique]